first thing is the overall picture as we
all know has been encouraging over the
last 20 30 years and around three
quarters of us now will survive cancer
for at least a year if we get it
compared to perhaps half of us when you
and i were growing up but um the real
issue is early diagnosis and
we know that with cancer if we can catch
it early we've got a very good chance of
dealing with it and someone surviving
but what we've found is that the nhs has
this big ambition to diagnose three
quarters of cancers at stage one or two
by 2028 it's in their long-term plan and
our report found they were not on track
to deliver that
and in fact they could miss about 340
000 early diagnosis
by then unless they turn things around
so the government knows this is an issue
it is taking a number of steps but we
want to raise the red flag in this
report and say that a lot more needs to
be done
how much has it done to the fact that
people were hesitant to come forward
during the pandemic as opposed to not
being called forward
well the pandemic was a major blow
across the uk around 45 000 fewer people
started treatment for cancer during the
first year of the pandemic and
unfortunately some people will die as a
result of that
but even before the pandemic the
fundamental issue is the cancer
workforce we find that we're about 200
oncologists short 2000 radiologists
short 4 000 cancer nurses short so
although the government is very welcome
is investing in more diagnostic centers
about 200 of those across england unless
you have the staff to operate these
centers you're going to have these
backlogs and that's why we think sorting
out the cancer workforce
uh which we would like some independent
system to make sure that we're actually
training enough doctors and nurses for
the future
is absolutely essential
looking back i mean you were i think you
were health secretary 2012 to 2018 um we
weren't training enough doctors and
nurses um from
20 in the early 2010s um
why was that
well i think it's always
not a high enough priority for health
sectors and chancellors when they're
discussing spending reviews they all
they're thinking about the immediate
pressures a winter crisis um what are we
going to do to pay for you know new
drugs and so on and the number of
doctors that you're going to have in
seven or 10 years time because that's
how long it takes to train a doctor is
never as high enough priority as it
should be i set up five new medical
schools so i did try to do something
about this
but i think we need to have a system
that doesn't depend on whether an
individual health secretary is
interested in the issue but permanently
deals with the issue to make sure that
whoever is in power whichever party
whichever health secretary we're always
training enough doctors and nurses for
the future
looking back do you feel that you and
your then
chancellors could have done more
well you you can always
have done more but i did increase the
number of doctors that we train by 25
which is one of the biggest ever
increases
but because it takes seven years not not
a single additional doctor has yet
reached the nhs workforce because of
those decisions so i think that's why we
need a structural change that makes sure
that year in year out we are always
training enough doctors and nurses for
the future because you know i think
doctors and nurses on the front line
understand that there isn't an overnight
solution to these issues it does take
time to train up people in the clinical
workforce but they do want to know that
there is at least a long-term solution
in place and that's why it's very
disappointing this week
the government is planning to stop the
house of lords
trying to amend the health bill to make
sure that we do train enough doctors and
nurses for the future they
blocked it in the house of commons last
week
and i think this is a real mistake
because if we're going to diagnose these
cancers earlier we need enough people to
operate the equipment
one of the options would be to recruit
uh doctors from overseas but when we
spoke last week he felt that that wasn't
ethical so what's the alternative
well we it's always been a kind of get
out of jail card for the nhs to increase
international recruitment and we have
absolutely brilliant doctors and nurses
from abroad in the nhs about a quarter
of our doctors were foreign born or
foreign trained
but
what i was talking to you last week was
whether it is really ethical to keep
recruiting doctors from for example
african countries that desperately need
them at home
and in fact
even if we wanted to it's not becoming
possible anymore because we've got a
global shortage of about two million
doctors across the world according to
the world health organization
so everyone needs more doctors and more
nurses and the only long-term solution
is for us to train
as many as we're going to need and we
have so many young people who leave
school and university and want to go
into medicine and find they're denied
the chance to do so surely it's the time
to put that right